as the war rages over here in Gaza
mediation efforts are being led by Qatar
a tiny Peninsula on the Persian Gulf
1100 miles away the country has used its
close ties with both Hamas and the West
to negotiate the release of hostages
from Gaza and get others out through the
border crossing with Egypt it's just the
latest example of qatar's important role
on the world stage from helping the US
evacuate thousands of people from
Afghanistan to brokering a prisoner swap
deal between the US and
Iran here's how Qatar became such an
important player in global
diplomacy qatar's location and economic
clout make it strategically important to
a lot of different countries it shares
its only land border with Saudi Arabia a
major power in the Middle East and it
shares the world's largest natural gas
field right here with Iran saudi's
biggest Regional Rial exports of
liquefied natural gas have made Qatar
one of the wealthiest countries in the
world boosting its influence in this
volatile region this has made Qatar a
critical energy partner for a lot of
countries especially those in Europe
because the continent has been reducing
its Reliance on Russian oil and gas
Qatar is also important to the United
States and right here is the biggest US
military base in the Middle East it's
been a launching pad for operations in
Afghanistan Iraq and Syria last year the
US made Qatar a major non-nato Ally
Qatar has also made itself influential
in the broader region through Al Zer the
largest news media Network in the Middle
East but it has been criticized in both
the Arab world and the West for its
sometimes controversial coverage of
uprisings wars and other
conflicts for example the network
broadcast video messages from Osama Bin
Laden after
911 nevertheless kutar Prides itself on
being a meeting place for diverse
viewpoints which was on full display
when the country hosted the World Cup
last year and its ambassador to the US
recently wrote an opinion piece in the
Wall Street Journal claiming that Qatar
is the mid east's honest broker in the
1980s and 90s the country's leaders
developed relationships with Iran as
well as Regional groups like Hamas in
the Palestinian territories and the
Muslim Brotherhood in Egypt groups that
are considered terrorist organizations
in some parts of the world it also
fostered ties with the Afghan Taliban in
2013 the Taliban opened a political
office in Qatar with support from the US
and Afghan governments years of
negotiations in Doha led to a deal in
2020 for US troops to withdraw from
Afghanistan ending America's longest
war but the agreement didn't bring peace
to the country the Taliban never reached
a power-sharing agreement with the
Afghan government and it seized control
of kabell in 2021 Qatar helped to
evacuate US citizens in the aftermath
and it is now Washington's diplomatic
representative in the country Hamas also
opened a political office in Qatar in
2012 after a request by the Obama
Administration to establish indirect
lines of communication and Qatar has
provided financial aid to Palestinians
in Gaza which is run by Hamas that has
led to accusations of funding terrorism
which Qatar
denies qatar's complex web of
relationships has caused friction with
its neighbors in 2017 it was blockaded
by Saudi Arabia the UAE Bahrain and
Egypt they accused Doha of meddling in
their domestic affairs supporting
extremist groups and being too close to
Regional rival Iran the four countries
issued a list of Demands including
shutting down alaz and reducing ties
with tan even though Qatar didn't make
concessions the blockade ended in
January of 2021 and the terms of the
deal haven't been made public although
the country's reestablished relations
some analysts say that the root causes
of that diplomatic crisis haven't been
resolved today qatar's diplomatic
relationships are in the spotlight once
again again with the country negotiating
the releasee of hostages taken from
Israel into Gaza by
Hamas but Qatar said that without a
pause in the fighting in Gaza its
mediators won't be able to do their work
it's a very very difficult negotiation
uh that we've been dealing with um um I
always say that one of the most
difficult mediation is a difficult
between two parties that have zero
confidence in each other Israeli
officials have said that qatar's efforts
are crucial at this time
but so far only a few hostages have been
released and when the crisis is over
many of qatar's Partners wanted to expel
Hamas leaders from the country that
includes more than 100 members of
Congress who signed a letter to
President Biden Qatar said that the
political office of Hamas will remain
open as long as it can be used toward
peace some diplomats worry that those
Hamas leaders could move somewhere more
hostile to the West like Iran or Syria
that could make any communication
between Hamas Israel in the west even
more complicated in situations like the
one that is currently unfolding in the
Middle
[Music]
East